okay today I'm with Barney's Coates a
lifelong advocate and fighter of Sharia
law how are you getting on with um in
Parliament you trying to have some laws
passed changed yes how's that going
well we're deeply concerned about the
way many Muslim women are suffering in
this country from this aspect of Sharia
law which are inherently gender
discriminatory and the threat to the
fundamental principles one of the ladies
spoke today suffered horrendously from
that the polygamy the so-called honor
based balance and the other issue of
quarters together here today are those
victims who have suffered so horrendous
neck at the hands of the Muslim gang
raping situations they gave their story
had no courage to tell their stories we
know that gang raping empty faces not
Muslim but in these particular cases
there are manifesting ideologically
based and encouraged and it is something
which should not be allowed to happen in
this country the other point which I
wish to make very strongly is that many
who sought help from the authorities
such as the police or social workers
have not had the help they needed
because they were so afraid the police
and others in political correctness are
being seen to be Islamophobic and these
people have been left very vulnerable
and not receiving the help that they
need so it's very important to come
together today speak out I have nothing
but admiration for the women who have
suffered so much who've had the courage
to speak out and I hope their voices
will not have been spoken in
okay I'm sure you knew was it I think
it's wrought steel does the first female
Sharia judge yeah and she's appreciate
proving 50 noodled marriages how do you
feel about that it's part of it it's one
of the symptoms of the awful situation
which we're trying to challenge today
the there's aspects of Sharia law which
are inherently discriminated one Muslim
lady said to me I feel betrayed by
Britain and I came here to get away from
all this no it's worse here than in the
country I came from today and you travel
the world and with you activism don't
you do indeed I've got to do besides my
like one is humanitarian working victims
freshman persecution come tonight
Nigeria Sudan the other is this whole
issue of women suffering from the
totally unjust and often they cool
aspect of Sharia law and ugly speaking
about that and as a kind of an insider
you know to Parliament where do you
think this way and I see Britain being
divided into Sharia and 1/2 M rule of
law on the other if you have enough
people voting for Sharia work uno al
hafi live under
wrong-o right return I'm driving in the
private member's bill which would at
least address some of the problems
causes of suffering to the women it
would require every Islamic law mine
would require every religious marriage
to be legally registered at the moment
the majority and not they were legally
registered then the respectful divorce
of amsuman or some three times would no
longer apply the polygamy which is
widespread would not be legally allowed
because we don't live bickerman
and it would also have a premium
protection the games are so-called honor
faced farmers so that is one step maybe
in the right direction has certainly
support a lot of support for Muslim
women's groups here but of course it is
still a lot going on out there that we
need to speak up that and a half wager
book do you have any more books coming
out I'm not at the moment but I have
quite a few out that I think and I'm
happy to give you a list including one
on this but related to this base subject
exam is the misery is political Islam
comparing liberal democracy I read my
late colleague John Marx and it's a
recommended reach thank you so much
Byron ases thank you